Jimbo Gena was a former Secret Service
agent and he joins us tonight dan I'm a
little bit confused seeing and calls
itself a news network they have their
own media reporter that squeaky kid who
speaks for Jeff Zucker they have said
virtually nothing about this on the air
why aren't they covering this I wonder
yeah incredible right Tucker how the
intensity of the coverage seeps through
the apps dramatically I was reading a
piece earlier today that and the first
day of this or two days of this to be
precisely with 43 minutes of coverage on
the Sandman case using Chiron's at lower
third of the screen we all see an
industry lingo things like bigotry and
harassment on the half on behalf of
these kids and taunting on behalf of
these kids you know I thought this was
the network remember their thing tucker
they had that little viral ad this is an
apple you can call it a banana but this
is an apple well apparently it's not an
apple when CNN becomes a focus of their
own terrible coverage is it ethical to
not report on your own role in a major
news - as a major news story this
lawsuit no of course not I mean listen
on the opinion side and up do whatever
you want those are opinion shows and
they're based on people's opinion but if
you're claiming to be a news network and
that's why I brought up CNN's ad that
this is an apple it's not a benign other
words we're at journalism Network we get
the facts right like in journalism you I
can't say this enough and Henry always
gets a kick at us you have one job in
journalism one job to put out the facts
it's the public's job to then form an
opinion based on an accurate statement
of facts CNN is proclaiming on their
news side on their news kids that they
had the facts in this case Tucker when
they didn't they had the matter of fact
they had the entire story backwards it
would completely backwards so no it is
not ethical they should do the right
thing and give the same intensity of
coverage to their screw up as they as
they did initially to the story about
salmon which was inaccurate right I mean
they're dishonest so I guess we
shouldn't be surprised but wouldn't it
have been no even we're not wise or from
a legal perspective just I mean they
slandered the guy obviously all of these
kids they called them race as they
mischaracterized the Native American
activists as a tribal elder and a
Vietnam veteran they lied about a lot of
differ
things why didn't they just apologize
for it I don't know if it's some kind of
well you know I'm kind of laughing here
because your opening segment today by
the way you know was was awesome about
Russian collusion this is the same
network who when I workout in the gym
it's the only TV in the whole gymnast
one guy puts CNN on Tucker it's the only
get only TV an old gym that's and it's
the only time I see CNN it's an all day
hyperbolic fest about a fictitious folks
called collusion if they're not going to
apologize for that why would they bother
apologizing you're right
I mean it's like I told you there's more
evidence for Sasquatch than there is for
half the stuff CNN puts on the air
that's exactly right yeah I believe in
so much I wouldn't believe a word they
say great to see you Syfy shadow buddy
yeah see you later man